[Music]
queen elizabeth ii makes her big return
to work in person for the first time
since false rumors of her death last
month which came during her battle with
covet 19. everything at the palace is
business as usual ticking along and far
from alarm bells clanging there really
is no real concern about the queen's
health the courtiers i've spoken to have
used the word cautious more than any
sense of alarm so i think we should be
focusing on that rather than any
sensationalists and false reports that
people may be reading and hearing about
online on monday the 95 year old monarch
met canadian prime minister justin
trudeau at windsor castle irl
that's hrh rocking pearls a blue
patterned dress and flats for the
occasion where she shook hands with a 50
year old politician who sported a blue
suit and purple tie
of course this all comes after queen
elizabeth tested positive for covet 19
on february 20th and was experiencing
mild cold-like symptoms
she's suffering a cold bit of a red nose
bit of a sniffle but really not much
more than that of course there has been
concern over the queen's health since
the palace confirmed that she has been
diagnosed with covid and understandably
so she's 95 her age alone makes her
vulnerable at the time et learned she's
both vaccinated and boosted i have
spoken to senior palisades who assure me
that the queen is um in good spirits and
she's suffering cold-like symptoms and
that is why she chose to cancel a recent
virtual audience i think anyone that's
got a cold and a runny nose just not
feeling 100
the last thing they want to do is be on
camera and have to do an audience
following her diagnosis the queen
canceled virtual appearances
but according to buckingham palace she
carried on with some work from home i'm
told that the queen is at her desk she's
doing light duties she's reading her
government papers she's got her red
boxes being delivered to her daily so
i take that as an indication that she's
not quite feeling up to being on camera
understandably so but absolutely up to
doing light duties and some desk-based
work so i think that's all very
encouraging
and while a source confirmed to et that
the royal had her weekly call with
united kingdom prime minister boris
johnson an in-person diplomatic
reception that was set to be held at
windsor castle was postponed amid the
monarch's health concerns but just days
later the queen was seen for the first
time since testing positive for kovid 19
appearing in two virtual gatherings
looking chic as ever in green
after her appearances a source told et
that she was on the mend and had been
zooming with family members from her
apartment in windsor castle while
recovering
[Music]
you